Poseidon Lord of the sea the god of
drought floods earthquakes and horses
but most importantly one of the
Olympians that I still haven't covered
for some reason and I know some of you
have been asking for almost two years
now so I guess it's finally time with
the video of this magnitude we should
probably start at the very beginning
with the Mycenaean religion essentially
the mother to all Greek myth before we
begin we have to put aside any image of
the Greek pantheon that we think we have
because the Mycenaean Pantheon is pretty
much the foundation that all others were
built from to the Mycenaeans Poseidon
was pretty much the figurehead of their
religion the role that we now associate
with Zeus originally belonged to him
even Persephone was considered the
daughter of Demeter and Poseidon as
opposed to Zeus but most of this can be
attributed to the fact that Zeus is a
deity that doesn't appear until much
later one of the earliest stories that
we have of Poseidon involves him
transforming into a horse to mate with
Demeter who had previously transformed
herself into a mare this whole
transformation into an animal to mate of
someone is something that we see
numerous times all throughout Greek myth
the Mycenaeans did still see poseidon as
the god of earthquakes but he was mostly
associated with the underworld and its
many rivers which in itself is quite
interesting because that is a role we
would more commonly associate to his
other brother Hades but in the absence
of his brothers Poseidon was pretty much
the three-in-one Swiss Army knife deity
it's hard to say with any real certainty
if the Mycenaeans
ever saw Poseidon as the god of the sea
because we just don't know enough about
the culture nor the people but the poets
that followed seemed to agree that this
association to the sea only came after
his father was defeated
as the years passed and many different
versions of the Greek religion came and
went
Poseidon became one of the original six
Olympians the children of Cronus and
Rhea whom all except Zeus were swallowed
at Birth by their father there are some
versions of the story where Poseidon was
also given away by his mother
same way Zeus was but these are much
harder to come by when they eventually
did manage to overthrow their father the
three brothers drew straws to see how
the world would be divided and who would
rule which domain but Zeus never
intended for this to be a fair contest
and so the underworld was given to Hades
when he drew the shortest straw
Poseidon would then take the sea when he
drew the second shortest straw and Zeus
emerging victorious will of course
become the ruler of the sky it's quite
rare to see images of Poseidon without
his iconic Trident and when his name is
mentioned I'm sure the Trident is what
comes to mind for most people during the
War of the Titans Seuss freed the
Cyclopes from Tartarus and in exchange
they forged the gods their weapons and
this is where Poseidon would receive his
Trident the symbol that would identify
the God and ruler of the sea of course
Poseidon wasn't the only date he
associated of the sea there were many
that came before him from pontus and
Thalassa which literally means sea to
Oceanus and the many minor deities and
children that followed the reason we
refer to him as the god of the sea is
because that is the role he took as
ruler and it's much easier to refer to
one than heaven to name all 10,000
seeing as we are on a topic of thousands
of deities I guess we can look at
Poseidon's lovers and many many children
the sadly I can't mention every single
one because YouTube does limit how long
videos can be that and I'd like to
remain somewhat sane at least until the
Zeus video or maybe even dark old
episode - they're coming soon I promise
that is if my neighbors would stop
howling like baboons and operate in
heavy machinery for two seconds so I can
actually record a video I've never
really wished harm on anyone but
theoretically if lightning did happen to
strike the exact area that my neighbors
were in that would mean I can upload
more than one video every four hundred
years which would be pretty damn good
just throwing that out there for anyone
who wants to help me out
looking at you Zeus there's a reason
that both Hades and Poseidon got a video
before you so you know you on that video
you better get to work
I guess these random tangents have just
become like a staple of most videos and
I'm just gonna leave them in now for the
few comedic ly challenged out there that
think I'm being serious and that was a
joke I don't actually want my neighbors
to get hit by lightning even if they do
make it impossible for me to make videos
but theoretically if a black hole opened
up and swallowed them I can't say I'd
miss them too much anyway back on a
topic of Poseidon's many lovers and
children I guess we should start with
his wife and fateh righty and the rather
weird story of how they got married when
Poseidon made it known that he wished to
marry Amphitrite she attempted to flee
in the hopes of remain in a virgin
rather than pursue her himself
Poseidon sent his dolphins to bring her
back and yes if you are wondering
dolphins are pretty much dolphins except
they were spirits in the service of
Poseidon it's never really stated where
they originated from just that they were
amongst his most beloved followers there
are two different versions of this story
one being that the Dolphins kidnapped
him for trotty and brought her back
against her will and the other being
that one dolphin in particular managed
to convince her to come back and marry
Poseidon it's because of the actions of
this one lone dolphin that the dolphin
were actually placed in the sky as the
constellation Delphinus there is an
additional part of this story written by
Roman poets where the Delfin responsible
for persuading Amphitrite to come back
actually organizes and officiates the
wedding now as where does this entire
story maybe I'm sure if people could get
married by dolphins today then there are
those that would I don't know why
because the obvious animal of choice to
marry you would be a penguin because it
already looks like they're wearing a
tuxedo and if you disagree well you're
just wrong so I'm fit right he married
Poseidon and became the queen of the sea
together they had two children of note
a son named Triton whose image is often
confused of that of his father because
he also carries around a trident the
main difference between the two was that
Triton had the upper body of a man but a
fish's tail pretty much just making him
a giant Merman the Triton ease was also
the name given to see spirits that
resembled mermen so I guess that is one
of the possible origins they also had a
daughter named ro DOS who was the
personification of the Greek island
known as Rhodes but not every poet seems
to agree that Poseidon was the father
rather that she was the daughter of
Amphitrite and an unnamed man regardless
both Amphitrite and Triton lived with
Poseidon in his golden palace found in
the Aegean Sea similar to Hades he spent
most of his time away from Olympus
unless he was called upon while married
to Amphitrite one of his many lovers was
the nymph Scylla
when Amphitrite eventually found out
about this affair she transformed Scylla
into the hideous monster of the sea that
we've come to know according to the poet
known as Poseidon then transformed her
from this hideous form into a coastal
cliff found in the Straits of Messina he
was so father to twins who were born
from Medusa's neck when she was beheaded
by Perseus
the winged steed Pegasus and Christ saw
the boy born with a golden sword also
known as the golden giant it's not a
huge surprise but he also had an affair
with Aphrodite
shortly after Aries and her were
released from her Festus Ezeli eminent
affair while she was still married to
him this is where it begins to sound
like one of those TV dramas targeted at
bored housewives when they were caught
by her Festus most of the gods thought
it was hilarious to be caught in the act
but Poseidon didn't find this funny and
so he pretty much pleaded and convinced
her Festus to let them go and I guess
this is where in order to show her
gratitude she then had an affair with
Poseidon so at this point in the Real
Housewives of Olympus I don't really
know who's supposed to be cheating on
who Aphrodite was still married to her
Festus when she had her fail
Aries but then she obviously left him
for Aries to have an affair with
Poseidon who was still married to
Amphitrite and just to make everything
even more confusing if Amphitrite x'
daughter was from an unnamed man does
that mean she had an affair on Poseidon
while he was doing the very same I
oughta stay have no clue but if you
think that's confusing then wait till we
get to Zeus his love life I personally
recommend that you take my approach when
it comes to the gods and their many
relationships just nod your head say oh
okay then and accept that there's no
point in searching for any semblance of
logic and move on the children of
Poseidon are pretty much an endless list
he fathered God's demigods and nymphs
and Giants animals as well as a host of
mortal children so a good rule of thumb
in Greek myth is if it breathes there's
a good chance it came from either Zeus
or Poseidon some of his most famous
mortal children included Bellerophon
Theseus and Lamia it's also pretty
ironic that many of the gods hated the
Giants but Poseidon was father to quite
a few include in Orion
Otis kreisau and the a Lodi but I'm sure
the offspring that you want to hear
about the most was the animal offspring
we already mentioned Pegasus and with
Poseidon being the god of horses it
makes sense that he would have more than
one horse child so along with the flying
horse Pegasus there was also Ariane the
fastest of all horses who could also
speak there was also Christ Samaras a
Golden Fleece fly in RAM who was also
capable of speaking pretty much Pegasus
Aryan and Christ all rolled into one
so either the ancient Greeks ran out of
ideas or after years of experimentation
Poseidon had finally created the best
mutant Ram child thing I'll leave you to
decide
so with that out of the way I guess we
can take a look at some of the stories
that Poseidon was involved in which is
quite a few I'm sure many of you have
heard the story of Perseus using
Medusa's head to slay the sea monster
Cetus and save Andromeda this entire
scenario only occurred because Queen
Cassiopeia made the claim that her
daughter was the most beautiful of all
the land even more so than the
narratives the maidens of the sea who
protected sailors and fishermen
Poseidon's wife also happened to be one
of the naira teased and so the thought
of his wife's beauty being compared to a
mere mortal angered him enough to where
he summoned the monster Cetus to destroy
their entire kingdom the king and queen
not known what to do then tied their
daughter to a pair of rocks and offered
her as a sacrifice to the monster in
order to appease Poseidon but this is
where Perseus swoops in saves the day
and kills the monster it wasn't really
uncommon to see Poseidon pop up in a
story retaliate because someone angered
him and then just disappear when
Odysseus blinded these Cyclops
Polyphemus he turned to his father to
help him get revenge and he did
eventually answer his sons prayers send
in a huge storm to destroy your dishes
ship and leave him and his men stranded
delay in their journey home for an
additional 10 years another pretty well
documented story was his dispute with
the goddess Athena as to who would
become the patron of Athens as it was a
city plagued by drought
Poseidon slammed his Trident against the
ground and created the people a spring
but the only water to come from this
spring was salt water so it was pretty
much useless
Athena then gave the people an olive
branch which they preferred because it
provided food firewood and it also
represented peace and so she became
their patron deity leaving Poseidon less
than happy with the outcome in the story
of the Minotaur King Minos prayed to
Poseidon to present him with a splendid
bull from the depths of the ocean so he
could show the people of Crete that the
gods favored him and that he was the
rightful king he promised Poseidon that
he would then sacrifice
the bull in his honor should he grant
his prayer shortly after the most
splendid white bull Minos had ever seen
appeared before him and once his people
saw this he became the king of Crete now
that was time to keep his side of the
bargain
Venus had grown fond of the bull and
thought he could trick Poseidon by
swapping the bull of another from his
hand this of course didn't work and
Poseidon turn the bull feral but he
didn't stop there he then made it so
Minos his wife fell in love of this bull
and after having Daedalus build her a
wooden cow she climbed inside and had
sex with said bull from that rather odd
form of bestiality she had a child this
child would of course be the Minotaur
who would plague Minos his kingdom so we
are starting to learn that making
poseidon angry doesn't end very well the
same can be said for most gods but Zeus
and Poseidon tend to find the most
creative ways to punish those guilty of
hubris there was also the time that the
gods rebelled against Zeus during the
COO of Olympus and as a result both
Apollo and Poseidon were stripped of
their divinity and placed in the service
of King la Madonna who had them build a
wall around the city of Troy promising
to reward them once it was finished the
king went back on his word
and so Poseidon once again sent a sea
monster to destroy the city after
consulting with an Oracle she told the
king that the only way to save his
people was to tie his daughter to a rock
and offer her as a sacrifice very
similar to the story of Perseus and
Andromeda but this time it will be
Heracles who killed the monster
throughout the trojan war poseidon
intervenes several times helped in the
greeks over the Trojans but that is
something we can discuss further when we
cover the Trojan War itself the cult of
Poseidon may arguably be one of if not
the biggest throughout ancient Greece it
did have some presence in central Greece
but the majority of his statues and
temples were built in southern Greece
and around the coastal islands which
does make sense as many of his followers
would have been sailors and fishermen it
became a fairly new more custom amongst
fishermen to take a bull down to the
sure and sacrifice it in Poseidon's name
believing that he would then grant them
a bountiful catch the very next day they
would then sacrifice a tenth of what
they caught to the Delfin so they
wouldn't destroy their fishing nets and
to Poseidon so he would grant them safe
passage home averting any disaster at
sea many also believed that he could
create new islands by merely driving his
Trident into the ground but the same
goes when he was angered by smashing his
Trident down he would cause earthquakes
floods and all sorts of destruction to
ships and fishing villages hence one of
his names being the Earthshaker some
would even drown horses during storms
because they believed this was the only
way to appease him but this also sounds
like a pretty good way to piss him off
pretty quickly for those wondering how
Poseidon travelled swimming doesn't seem
like the most efficient way so instead
he rode a chariot pulled by the
hippocampus horses with a fish tail so
pretty much giant sea horses there will
always be an argument as to whether
Poseidon should have been the rule of
the Gods over Zeus similar to that of
the Mycenaean iteration ultimately there
isn't really a way of determining this
without just arguing about which one of
the two you prefer Zeus was the ruler
because that is what the ancient Greeks
decided so arguing that they were wrong
about their own religion is pretty
pointless the poets and historians
didn't come up with some kind of power
scale we can measure there are some
quotes about Poseidon being able to rule
if he wished but most agree that Zeus
possessed the most authority and that is
the only reliable way to determine power
without speculation so to answer the
question that so many people ask who is
stronger Zeus or Poseidon the answer is
very simply Zeus
because if Pokemon has taught us
anything it's that thunder is super
effective against water
if you would like a video detailing all
of Poseidon's lovers and children then
let me know in the comments below so I
can make sure to ignore all of you
because that's never gonna happen but on
a more serious note do leave a comment
and I like because it does help with
video interaction I've also been told
that it drastically increases your
chances of not being hit by lightning
which is pretty damn good so do it
unless you happen to be one of my
neighbors as always I've been your host
mythology and random tangents explained
[Music]